♪♪
-♪ Hey, now ♪
-♪ We never knew how to forfeit ♪
-♪ But we always knew how to talk ♪
-♪ Hey, now ♪
-♪ Couple nights, threw gasoline on the fire ♪
-♪ We never knew how to perfect ♪
-♪ Hey, now ♪
-♪ We always knew it would work 'cause if something misread ♪
♪ Or if something got said ♪
♪ Know before the night ends ♪
♪ No, don't get stressed, it's gon' get figured out ♪
♪ Oh, deep conversations at the waffle house ♪
♪ Headstrong father and a determined mother ♪
♪ Oh, that's why some nights we try to kill each other ♪
♪ But you know it's always love ♪
-♪ Hey, now ♪
-♪ We never knew how to fake it ♪
-♪ But we always knew how to break ♪
-♪ Hey, now ♪
-♪ Couple nights, threw gasoline on the fire ♪
♪ 'Cause if something misread or if something got said ♪
♪ Know before the night ends ♪
♪ Don't get stressed, it's gon' get figured out ♪
♪ Oh, deep conversations at the waffle house ♪
♪ Headstrong father and a determined mother ♪
♪ Oh, that's why some nights we try to kill each other ♪
♪ But you know it's all in love ♪
-♪ Na-na-na ♪
-♪ Oh, yeah ♪
-♪ Na-na-na-na ♪
-♪ You know it's all love ♪
-♪ Na-na-na ♪
-♪ Yeah, yeah ♪ -♪ Na-na-na-na ♪
-♪ But you know it's always gon' get figured out ♪
♪ Deep conversations at the waffle house ♪
-♪ Headstrong father and a determined mother ♪
-♪ Oh, that's why some nights, we try to kill each other ♪
♪ You know it's always love ♪
-♪ Na-na-na ♪
-♪ Yeah, yeah ♪ -♪ Na-na-na-na ♪
-♪ You know it's always love ♪
-Yeah. -Hey!
-Wow! Well done. -All right.